Turners is a family business.
It actually started with two Turner brothers in 1930.
One drove a lorry when he was eighteen, and the other one was sixteen...
...and he helped to load the lorry, and they took produce that was grown locally...
...to the flower markets and the vegetable markets in London.
They developed it from there.
And in 1952, it became a limited company and the name Turner Soham Limited was founded then,...
...and they slowly grew the vehicles and started refrigerated transport in the early 70s...
...when right at the foundation of that.
And really by the time I joined the business in the 80s,...
...we were a relatively large East Anglian based haulage company.
We operated 120 vehicles and we had a good foundation to try and develop,...
...grow the company from there.
Well, during the 80s we continued to try and develop and grow the business...
...and we were becoming more and more known as a refrigerated transport company.
And then, we had the opportunity...
...to buy a small business that was involved in powder tankers,...
... and by the early 90s, it was clear that we needed to specialise in, and really we were...
...our core strength was the refrigerated market.
We were gaining new business in the tanker market...
...and really we decided to focus on those two areas to develop the business further.
In this century, about five years ago, I had always wanted to go into fuel,...
...and we got an opportunity to run a few fuel tankers...
...and that has proved to be very successful for Turners,...
...and we have managed to grow that in five years...
...to have around about 200 vehicles now operating on fuel deliveries.
So, we are the third biggest in the UK now in fuel after five years.
So, I think we have done very well in that sector.